what is very very clear is that there's
something systemically wrong with these
institutions they are maladapted they
are a little bit like the dinosaurs that
are watching this Comet you know the
streak down the sky and are about to uh
it's about to hit the ground they at
least have no real
um ideality other than control and
they've gone to identity because it
provides control they have lost their
Authority but now they can have Control
the Chaos is not going to go away we're
not going to go back to quote normal
there's a tremendous stream uh of of
politics in the United States I don't
know if it's not that anywhere else I
suspect that it is that once I get back
to normal this is crazy stuff you know
this idea that men aren't men and women
aren't women God can we go back well
we're never going to get back to normal
okay
all right
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantine kitchen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People our brilliant guest today is the
author of The Revolt of the public and
the crisis of authority in the New
Millennium Martin Guri welcome to
trigonometry
thank you it's great to have you on the
show fascinating read fascinating
Concepts that you lay out but before we
get into that tell everybody who are you
how are you where you are what has been
the journey through life that leads you
to be sitting here talking to us
the journey through life huh I mean look
at me or those of you those of you who
can't look at me should know that I am
not a young man so that that would be a
long answer I was born in Cuba
um before I was 10 I experienced
um
a right-wing dictator and a left-wing
totalitarian dictator so by the time I
came to the United States as a kid I I
already understood that democracy at its
worst was better than the next
alternative okay
um so I get to the US and um I have to
say I know that a lot of um
a lot of uh ink gets spilled virtually
gets spilled about the treatment of
immigrants in this country I I can't
recall a single instance of anything
other than being welcomed being a a
Cuban uh if anything was an advantage
with the girls
it never was a handicap and I have no
memory I mean at a very strange moment
my mind flipped and I went from thinking
in Spanish just thinking in English and
I remember my my Spanish life in English
in a very weird way
um
I my career was with CIA
I moved to the Washington area and and
uh I I was an analyst of global media
and we can talk about that more
extensively later if you want but I mean
it's at least least sexy job in CIA okay
like
um I I did not have my license to Kill
and I I the lady didn't fall madly in
love with me except my wife thankful
thankfully
um uh but it turned out to be the
strategically commanding Heights uh to
be at when
um the digital tsunami
hid the world okay so um while I was
there I watched that tsunami smack I
mean we were used to very very small
amounts of information open information
when I was looking at open media across
the world sometimes in the original
sometimes in Translation
um and we had this tiny little trickle
we got to play with and we knew what was
authoritative or what wasn't suddenly
there was this tile wave this tsunami
that swept over everything battered
everything what was authoritative in
that well beyond that question which had
never been answered uh behind that tidal
wave I could see and several of us could
see
um ever increasing levels of
socio-political turbulence things were
going haywire in places like Egypt for
example
um and I know it sounds kind of naive
now but at the time we were asking
ourselves what does this have to do you
know a Communications device like the
internet with politics I mean what you
know today of course we know so that the
two things are integrally connected and
of course the book was an attempt to you
know my my book which I I began to think
about when I left government
was an attempt to answer that question
what is the connection between
information structure and and political
change and we can get more deeply into
that the book was first published as an
ebook in 2014 it did okay then came 2016
and brexit happened and Donald Trump
happened and it did really really well
and then
um stripe press uh uh offered to publish
a second edition in in uh various
formats like heartbound and Audible and
that one came out at the end of 2018 and
of course all the madness I'm sort of
like Dr Doom you know whenever things go
terrible the books starts selling like
like uh like mad uh and of course we had
January 6th and the election so it did
fairly well after that so it's an
attempt to explain uh the madness the
craziness the the sort of like the
difference between the way things used
to be what we used to consider to be
normal life and what today seems to be
bombarding us from every direction
including uh the Hemorrhage of of
authority of our institutions that seem
to be uh very feeble and very distrusted
and one of the most interesting Concepts
when you talk about the digital tsunami
you're talking about the fact that
there's a huge amount of information
that is now available to the public that
in the past wouldn't have been and
that's combined or maybe even caused the
fact that you now have a rise of
populism which is in your conception
essentially people wanting revenge or
some kind of they want to punish perhaps
the the elites that they now
increasingly distrust and their leads
themselves have no idea what to do uh
they don't have the protection they used
to have one you know if you were a
member of the Lee and you were having
Affairs and whatever that wouldn't
really get into the Press most of the
time and you'd kind of be covered but
now every mistake you make as a member
of The League gets exposed people find
out about it and so you have this uh
crumbling of trust and their leads from
people who already don't like their
leads and the information flows that we
now have are increasingly amplifying
that so how how is this all impacting
our world
well I mean
basically you have to go back again I I
reluctantly hark back to the fact that I
am not a young man I lived in the 20th
century a chunk of my life okay a
considerable chunk
um and it was a different world it was a
different world it dealt with that
scarcity of information that I was
talking about that was so comfy when I
was a global media analyst and all our
institutions including our institutions
of politics and democracy uh but also
media and also the entertainment World
also
um uh scientific establishment the
Academia all of them basically were
resting on uh the fact that we had no
alternative sources of information so
they had Authority because they did have
each each institution had sort of a
semi-monopoly on a stream of information
so you know Walter Cronkite stood and
looked Us in the eye and this was a very
imposing man looked like a rich uncle or
something and and deep voice and he
would say that's the way it is for you
know February 2nd 2023 you didn't think
about the fact that he had given you
like 23 minutes of two or three visual
stories and that supposed to cover what
happened in the world that entire day
right you just thought well that's all I
got right
um that entire world was Swept Away by
the digital tsunami now we have massive
amounts of alternative information that
works both inside and outside the
institutions the president for example
in the olden days relied heavily in CIA
but increasingly would say wait I'm
reading this thing that's contrary to
what you say CIA so the authority of
entity was kind of like the president's
newspaper but like all newspapers it's
kind of losing Authority and credibility
why because there are so many
alternative sources plus where do these
sources come come from they don't come
from the top they come from the bottom
it's an eruption from the bottom of
information
um that it's essentially
um essentially represents a public that
is that is uh very angry at what it has
seen the old 20th century World promised
a lot uh when things were not delivered
it could serve put a lot of put a lot of
dirt under the carpet but also you know
it could sacrifice that individual a
Richard Nixon say uh and but say you
know the system worked we saved the
system what what is very very clear is
that there's something systemically
wrong with these institutions they are
maladapted and the elites as you say who
are on top of this is who basically
manage them and there are all the
institutions that make Modern Life
possible
um are
they are not looking forward they're
looking backwards they're very
reactionary that world you described
where you could have you could be JFK
and apparently this is a man who had
more affairs than a a person like me
could even conceive of all right
um and yet and I guess everybody knew it
on the in the inside circle of elite the
magic circle everybody knew this was
going on
um but those of us who were outside that
magic circle had no idea because he was
protected all right
um and that is what our current Elite
still well there's still too many
Boomers like me too many people who
remember or are nostalgic for the 20th
century and they want to drag us there
they want to drag us back there and and
yes they are very
um terrified they're very panicked but
they are working to get us back there
and if you look at Twitter files and all
the information that's been coming out
there there's a pretty concerted effort
to turn the information's fear the
current churning digital information
sphere into something that looks
something like on the front page of the
New York Times Circa you know 1985 or
something like that Martin so what are
the problems with these institutions
well the problems basically are they are
they are
um they are a little bit like the
dinosaurs that are watching this Comet
you know the streak down the sky and are
about to uh it's about to hit the ground
they are they were this great big
lumbering hierarchical things you know
mostly immobile uh that they're just
fine in the era of of like a mask
production Mass audiences everything was
top down the masses were included in
these institutions but at the bottom and
as basically passive recipients of what
the top was delivering right
um and uh in the digital age that that
that's basically you're dealing with a
very very
um chaotic environment that digital
tsunami is is uh it's very unforgiving
of these institutions unforgiving of the
people who run them shows every mistake
they make that didn't seem to come out
so much uh shows that they're promising
things and remembers what they promise
and it brings it back up uh in the olden
days there was a big memory hole you put
the things that you said you were gonna
do and that didn't get around to uh and
what could we do we had no way of
remembering we had no way of bringing it
up if we did
um and essentially we are as public we
live in a world that's fairly flat
relatively flat uh it moves at the speed
of light so that for example if I wanted
a a a something from Amazon uh I'm uh
you know just push a a button you know a
key and it's on my doorstep on the next
day but if I deal with my government it
takes months and months to get things
done it sometimes years sometimes never
okay depending on which side of the
government you're dealing with and um
and and the attitudes are very different
we're used to personalization in in the
digital world well no the the government
treats you and all these institutions
Academia for example three two uh so you
come to us and then we condescend to
talk to you in our own terms and then
you will you know applaud us because of
what we deserve
and and I think that method which is a
combination of structural problems
within the institutions and of
um rhetorical and and also almost moral
uh problems with the elite class that
runs the institutions
um I think it's it's made for a
tremendous collision between
that group and the rest of us many of
the rest of us anyway who are fed up
they're just not happy with the
situation what a change want government
to look are more like Amazon I mean
Amazon is a great big institution it's a
great big hierarchy it it uh but that's
not what you that's not what you um
encounter you encountered service
um that government gives you service but
that's not what you encounter you
encounter bureaucracy you encounter
condescension arrogance so we want one
thing to be more like the other uh I
think it's perfectly doable I don't
think the elites want to do it that's a
really really interesting point and
Martin how long do you think the elites
are going to be able to hold on to this
powerful because we're seeing in the UK
they're currently debating in the House
of Lords the Online safety Bill about
what people should and shouldn't be
allowed to say online and to me this
looks like another paragraph if I'm
putting it bluntly so how long do you
think they're going to be able to hold
on for
that's a really good question and I have
no answer I I don't make predictions
that you want to be wrong uh make a
prediction right CIA that that was a
cia's um entire business model was
prediction for the president and you
know as long as yesterday tomorrow looks
like yesterday yeah you're good man
that's most of the time believe it or
not but of course what people want to
know really the president is you know
discontinuities and we can't predict
those I don't know I've been surprised I
think because nobody predicted covid
which was the trigger where the public
was so afraid that they actually wanted
the elites to be what the elites had
been claiming to be from the 20th
century on which is we are the experts
we know we have solutions to problems so
there's some almost a mathematical
mindset to what our very squishy and and
uh difficult circumstances not problems
um but I think the public wanted
desperately for this to be a
mathematical problem that could be
solved right away by these wise people
that were telling us they could do it
and I think so then with nobody
complained too loudly when social media
was essentially centered uh so that
non-uh institutional opinions about
covid were were either muted or or just
blocked out uh from from the information
sphere and of course that took about
five seconds before it tipped over into
politics and and it was more of a
question you know well we need we need
to protect our democracy and we need to
protect our elections and there's
Russian hacking and suddenly everything
that a certain side you know the
progressive side found offensive had
become necessary to to um essentially
sensor uh and and
um
so how long can that last I'm a one who
believes that the internet is too big in
areas it's virtually infinite for for
human purposes it's infinite if you see
how much gets ingested by YouTube and
every minute you go like okay you can't
put a fact checker on every corner of
this enormous territory so I don't think
it can it can be it can be controlled
but I don't know I mean that's my guess
what you're describing sorry to
interrupt I love that lovers I am to
quote Vladimir Lenin but he said that
you know what A revolution is coming
when those at the bottom can't take it
anymore and those are the top don't want
to give up what they have and it sounds
to me like that is exactly the situation
that you're describing
well let's put it this way coming from
Cuba I'm not a real fan of revolutions
all right yes coming from Russia I'm
also not a big fan of revolutions
yeah so I and what you said is is has a
a big caveat attached to it okay I think
I think the short answer is it depends
on us all right where this heads depends
on us and if we're passive then the
elites will have what they had before in
a very
ramshackle much more ramshackle and
spotty way or they had some sort of
control because we just kind of
passively allowed it to happen as we did
during covet but the difference whether
with um with the Lenin quote and now is
that Lennon was ahead of what was a
typical
um 20th century revolutionary
organization which was when you looked
at that the Bolshevik party was a tiny
little hierarchy that longed and lusted
to take power and become the government
the state itself right
um and had a very powerful ideology that
it followed and and attach it or flowing
from that ideology had any number of
programs that would be imposed if you
took over the state because the
ideologies sort of suggested or mandated
that
the public today has oh and you had you
had a leader at the top of the
organization that could just say Atlanta
himself could say okay this is the way
it's going to happen I mean when Lenin
arrived at the Finland station he said
we're going to have a Revolution and the
entire his entire group said no we're
not and he said yes we are and they did
okay and he was right he called that
situation much more clearly than they
did today when you look at the Revolt of
the public and places like Chile places
like Spain with the indignados the U.S
with the occupiers black lives matter
there are no leaders
not only is there no ideology it's
almost anti-ideology there are no
programs okay there are there is no
coherent set of uh and there's no wish
there is no wish to take over Power by
any of these groups it is a very very
paradoxical thing they attack they
loathed uh the institution they load the
elites they load the government
and then they say we we hate this thing
about you fix it they're basically they
then seed to the government the
um the duty of Reform or revolution or
whatever you want to call it right which
of course never works never works so you
have for example in in uh in Egypt this
this crowd this this this Revolt
interior square
that probably was the determining factor
in getting the dictator the husband
Mubarak 30 years has been the power out
of there they got overthrown then what
happens well
who knows that the crowd had nothing to
do with what happened afterwards two
old-fashioned hierarchical institutions
the Egyptian Military and the Muslim
Brotherhood slugged it out for the next
few years the military won
but the public had nothing to do with
that because they had no ideology no
program no leaders no organization so
um yes you can say that we can't take it
anymore but what do we put in this place
what do we put in place and even January
6th is is in some ways an example of
that people quote unquote storm the
capital but they don't have a plan or a
program to do anything right
it's it's a it's an interesting point
that you make
this episode is brought to you by better
help
help Constantine what's the best thing
about having this episode sponsored by
betterhelp in my country mental health
is something that you have before you
start drinking thankfully we'll start
drinking at breakfast so we have no
problem really yes our slogan is drink
breakfast vodka and become real men okay
but if you do want to feel better inside
and out then maybe you should try better
help I have been doing therapy for over
a year and it has really helped me
understand myself better and become far
more effective in both my work and my
personal life I always knew you are not
real man pass me the Vodka therapy has
helped me transform myself so that I
take responsibility for my behavior and
my attitude you can't achieve your
dreams if you don't think you deserve to
every shot you drink make you feel
stronger what is problem and the great
thing about better help is that it's all
online and they can connect you with a
licensed therapist who can work with you
so that you can achieve your goals it
takes a few minutes to set up and it can
fit around your schedule I will never
forget my first love Olga orgasmachenko
and the Beautiful relationship that
could have been any if it's not working
for you with a particular therapist then
you can always switch at no extra charge
I am doomed to become Russian poet
discover your potential with better help
visit betterhelp.com
trigger today to get 10 off your first
month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash trigger
I have run out of breakfast Vodka it's
time for lunchtime Brandy
I suppose the big question that bothers
me in all of this is if we accept the
framing that in the past let's say Elite
institutions dictated to the public what
the truth was and there was General
consensus more or less about what the
truth was and of course people would
argue you know do we need communism or
do we need capitalism or do we need
socialism but it was still from a common
shared set of beliefs about the world
now we've got to a point where I think
the real problem is
we're getting to the stage where it's
hard to know what the truth is anymore
yeah I mean we're the moment of
post-truth and I don't mean that in the
way that
um
many
um liberal and Progressive uh thinkers
portray that that phrase which is both
truth is what Trump does for example or
what what um you know with people who
clearly lie uh and yet seem to have the
fact that they're telling something
that's not not factually correct seems
to have no effect on on the their
popularity
um that's only one aspect of it I think
it goes it cuts in every way the the the
digital dispensation has fractured us
has fractured that that is what it does
and it a case can be made that's the way
the public really is all right in other
words what we were before a mass
audience was a very artificial construct
that kind of served served the people
that were manufacturing to us and were
entertaining us on television so you had
two or three you know varieties of
everything and that we were happy with
that no I don't think so we would have
wanted much more uh and and so from
personalization on out we're very
fractured
um I think that that that that we're
kind of like um a mirror that has fallen
and we the public lives on the broken
shards and each Shard has a perspective
on reality I'm not a post-modernist okay
if you stand if I'm standing in the
middle of a street and I see a truck
coming at me I can't post-modern my way
out of being run over all right I I'm
gonna just jump and get out of the way
but most of what we deal with in our in
our society today most of the facts most
of the reality most of the truth that we
deal with in our society are mediated
they're given to us by someone starting
with your teachers and then all the way
out with authorities that you trust the
media and so forth and I think that is
what's also fractured and so post truth
is is uh the idea that in certain
quarters people still believe that
Donald Trump was colluding with the
Russians it has been pretty much refuted
you know with deep deep investigations
um
the Q Anon people that stormed
um a storm the um the Capitol building
believe that our government was run by a
pedophile ring right so I mean these are
so
the the dangerous side of that is that
at some point we disintegrate into
um uh the Tower of Babel we're all
speaking different languages and we're
kind of yelling at each other and
Jonathan height has a very interesting
article on that point he stole the
metaphor for me though I want to know
we'll take it up with him when we have
him on the show yeah and he acknowledged
it he acknowledges
yeah just two two more things that
there is a point at which you have to
you know somehow act and you have to act
on the reality that you understand to be
right and that's hard under these
conditions that's the dangerous side on
the plus side
tells us that we don't have a firm grasp
on truth that means the whole idea of
science is not that it grants us truth
is that we don't know truth and I think
maybe there's a healthy aspect to
realizing that there are different
perspectives on truth the truth is
perspectable it's not it's the
postmodern thing that's not constructed
it's perspectable and I can you know if
you are at the top of the Empire State
Building New York looks like the the the
the Heavenly City if you're at the
bottom of the Empire State Building you
know and there's a you know homeless
person wretching on the sidewalk and and
traffic and pollution it looks like hell
well it's the same New York City it just
depends on your perspective and I think
it's maybe it's it's it's good to have
our our sense our perspectives
questioned by others yeah I I I
completely agree with you Martin to me
and one of the questions I wanted to ask
you is that you talked about a lack of
ideology within these kind of Rebel
movements shall we just call them for
the sake of argument but there also
seems to be a lack of ideology in our
Elites as well doesn't it there doesn't
seem to be a consistent way of thinking
that they have
yeah I would say that's true to a
certain extent
um yes but
certainly in America the United States
um the elites have converted this
Mexican version I mean is that something
that I don't think anything has happened
since the age of emperor Constantine all
right the entire the entire
institutional set and I'm talking from
like you know crusty old
um corporations like Coca-Cola all the
way to the government to Academia to to
um entertainment to
um scientific establishment everybody
has converted to The Cult of identity so
I call it the established church right
so now identity is not
an ideology I identity sort of like a
Perpetual conflict machine yeah ideology
and ideally reconciles contradictions
and provides a context for uh a path to
Justice defined in a specific way right
um this is not the this is not like that
I mean this is this is more of a endless
jockeying grinding of who gets what you
know I'm a victim I'm a victim of a
victim but so
um there's but there is no way of
um
um basically justifying or or
ameliorating the conflict between
victims right so if you're a black
person you're you get precedence over a
white person but if you were a black
woman you should get proceedings over a
black man but if you're a black lesbian
you should get proceedings over a black
CIS lady right so so how does what is
the do you need analogy some gigantic
algorithm here or some kind of thing
like that to even work out how it
happens so yes you at least have no real
um ideality other than control and
they've gone to
um uh idea identity because it provides
control they have lost their Authority
but now they can have control they can
tell you you are not allowed to use that
word because it's offensive it causes
harm uh and of course all the words they
put in that stack at the are the the
words that convey opinions they don't
like yeah it's it's a really really good
point Martin and
talking about this kind of post-truth
world
but a post-truth world it's impossible
to have a cohesive Society because the
most important thing is that we all
agree that something is true and if we
can't do that then how can we have any
type of discussion or debate
well it's a little that's true but let's
not forget that liberal democracy is is
an amazing invention right and
um what you're describing is the world
of the 30 Years War right where I
believe in a certain kind of God and I
believe in a certain kind of
Christianity and a certain kind of uh
life that must follow from that and
because you believe in something very
slightly different the kind of thing
that from the perspective of History
seems almost insignificant right but
there's a few words difference between
what you believe and what I believe we
have to Now kill each other all right
um and and liberal democracy which
evolved out of that world as a way to
solve that dilemma well how do we do
that uh allowed for people who believed
in radically different religious Cosmic
views
sources of meaning which in the end are
the most important things to any human
being or to any Community to be side by
side with very different ones that
believe in very you know if you are
either an atheist that's not a minor
difference anymore or if you're a Muslim
or or a Jew that's not a minor
difference anymore and yet we all lived
peacefully uh with each other uh
Although our beliefs about Cosmic truth
were so different something like that
can be worked out you just have to want
to work it out the incentives in the
digital world unfortunately so far have
all been towards um conflict because we
do live in in the um
Tower of Babel people who speak with
soft voices are just not heard okay you
need to scream and if you can scream
with anger in your voice you catch a
little more attention and you can swim
with anger in your voice and you get
somebody on the other side to scream
back at you now you're suddenly a hero
right and people start to gather behind
you and behind the other person and you
have a sort of a heroic Battle of
Barbarians you know like like it used to
happen in the Dark Ages
um that's that's the incentive so far of
the digital world but it doesn't have to
be so how does this get fixed
oh well of course if I had the answer to
that I wouldn't be talking to you guys
I'd be counting my billions yeah
I mean I go back to what I said before
it's all up to us nothing is determined
I am not a determinist I don't believe
like like the marxists do that there is
a fixed
um direction of History I don't believe
there hold on hold on you I think would
agree with me that human beings first
and foremost respond to incentives and
if you have an incentive structure that
incentivizes conflict you will get
conflict and if you have an incentive
structure that doesn't incentivize
conflict and incentivizes cooperation
for example you will get cooperation so
as you say yourself in this current
climate particularly online we have an
incentive structure that incentivizes
people to antagonize each other to see
each other as enemies to see each other
as uh you know almost subhuman when I
observe people's interactions it feels
like
um so how do we change that incentive
structure because at this point it's not
just that it's a random accident of of
the fact that online seems to have
created this Facebook Twitter Instagram
Tick Tock they're all invested in this
YouTube is invested in this it benefits
them because these are the things that
get clicks online so how does this get
fixed
well I mean how how did the 30 Years War
end
right I mean in the end there are many
there were the same
um structure can be applied differently
so that the 30 years war ended with
exhaustion all right with exhaustion
look we're in the early early days of a
colossal transformation that uh from the
Industrial Age to something that doesn't
even have a name yet okay I I'm not
gonna see the end of that you guys I'm
looking at you you may not see the end
of it all right he's saying we're old
mate yeah we're not going to make it
well you can interpret it that way or
you can interpret that this is going to
be a long long process Okay so what is
going to be at the end okay when I say
it's up to us
the chaos is not going to go away we're
not going to go back to quote normal
there's a tremendous stream uh of of
politics in the United States I don't
know if it's not got anywhere else I
suspect that it is that once I get back
to normal this is crazy stuff you know
this idea that men aren't men and women
aren't women God can we go back well
we're never going to get back to normal
okay but we can carry to the end of this
process those things that are really
important to us for me is democracy for
example okay so what happened to 30
Years War was exhaustion all these um
religions fought themselves to a
standstill and suddenly something new
came up the the nation-state that said
the hell with this right we are now
going to impose uh a way of being that
that is is less destructive
um well we can't see what's going to be
happening in 10 15 20 years now but the
same incentive structure that the today
seems to generate
um a lot of views May 10 15 years down
the road make people sick because
they've been added for so long and then
the incentives will flip all right the
incentives will flip it's possible I'm
not saying it's going to happen I'm not
saying it's not going to happen it's up
to us no I think you're right and uh
action always causes some kind of
reaction and people will get fed up with
this and I already you know one of the
conversations we we obviously on this
show talked a lot about this Progressive
the excesses of progressive ideology and
how it's infected all sorts of different
Industries Etc but on the other hand a
lot of a lot of people I think in our
space are starting to think about okay
well we've identified what the problem
is what's the answer what is a positive
vision for the future that can people
can unite around that actually inspires
people so I suppose my question for you
is if it's up to us what is a
responsible person who's watching or
listening to this what are we to do
in our own lives about all of this
right okay start with this
all that anger or all that questioning
let's call it all that distrust all that
um uh pushiness let's call it
um that you are now aiming at people
that you don't even know and then
institutions that you have no access to
start by aiming that at yourself all
right and I'm always struck uh when I
look at the victorians the English
victorians okay that have such a
terrible reputation for being smug and
being self-righteous how not like that
they were all right go read Gladstone's
diary this man was
you know one of the great figures in the
world uh one of the great Prime
Ministers of of Britain
um and he was very Christian and his
diary was one gigantic self-questioning
and
the answers were he felt very inadequate
he was not yelling at everybody else for
not living up to his expectations he was
asking himself how can I be better and
he did some very strange things trying
to do that
um we can't get into that later if you
want
um but um but I think we need to start
with that we need to ask ourselves we
need to have a
a more thoughtful relationship with our
Elites uh the Spanish philosopher Jose
Garcia Jose Ortega set says we have a
mutual selective relationship with our
Elites so
think about the people that not just
that you vote for or the the parties
that you give money for but who do you
what what movies do you see you
patronize right what products do you buy
what companies do you give your money to
um you you are basically selecting an
Elite Class by doing that be more
thoughtful about that okay
um and we need a new Elite class I mean
honestly I think the current class we
have just is mired in 20th century
reactionary thinking and we need an
elite class this will not be solved
until that changes because
um I still I am not a radical
egalitarian dude nothing gets done
without institutions being added
institutions between hierarchy of some
kind and hierarchies are require leads
so they'll have to be shallower within a
class of Elites that is more comfortable
being far closer to the public than the
current Elite Class is
um and we have at least a part of a role
in selecting that Elite Class
and then be what what you would want
others to be and that part of the
reasons for example that I never say
make predictions is because it's
I mean it I would be pretending
to do something that I cannot do I in
principle we cannot predict the future I
would love for people to think that I
can that would make me a very important
person but if I do it and I fail I have
I have tarnished my Integrity I've
tarnished my my
um Authority as as anybody who knows
anything right so speak humbly speak uh
um directly and and don't dance around
and
and have some courage I think part of
what's happening to us now this is more
in the public side is uh people are
afraid to speak out because they can
lose their jobs they can lose their uh
they can be you know silenced in social
media they can be demonetized all kinds
of bad things can happen to you well
damn it you know do it do it if you
really believe in what you're doing you
know speak out do what um what uh Pope
John Paul said Be not Afraid Be not
Afraid and that he was talking about the
people in in places like Poland who are
in the communist government the
punishment there was a lot worse than it
is here so do it and I think I think if
that trajectory is followed
um this this entire you know churning
crazy uh Tower of Babel's circumstance
will start to crystallize in something
more manageable
hey KK do you like trigonometry of
course I do incredible interviews
fascinating guests phenomenal live shows
and hilarious raw streams in that case
you need to join our locals so you can
have access to even more brilliant
content that's right you get the chance
to win incredible prizes ask our
phenomenal guests to your questions
access extra content and now the only
place to watch our Roars on catch up is
on locals our war shows still go out at
7 pm UK time 2 p.m Eastern as normal but
if you want to watch some after this
time then you're gonna need to sign up
to our locals Ross have now become too
spicy to stay on YouTube so they're only
available to watch back on our locals
page all you need to do to sign up is
click on the link below this video and
for just seven dollars a month you have
access to All of This brilliant content
seven dollars a month even for someone
of my persuasion that's a bargain see
deal on locals
it's a really good point you make
do you think our institutions can be
saved or do you think we need to build
new institutions
I think both I think both
um I I think the the old institutions
certainly can't stay the way they are
and you look at political parties and
traditional political parties today and
it's no wonder that they completely just
withered up and they're they're just
shriveled versions of what they used to
be but there's so many different ways in
which you can run a political party I
mean you can run a political party like
a subreddit you know like you could just
say what is everybody interested in and
that the issues that the majority are
interested in to rise to the top and
then at least the elites that that run
the party understand what the base is
really really looking at not the other
way around which where the elites tell
the base this is what you're interested
in and everybody's shaking their heads
and nobody's listening right so
um
some some institutions I mean like the
newspaper is gone I mean that so there
are many institutions that are just
basically going to be swept away
um some are going to be drastically
altered and I believe our politics are
going to be very drastically altered
um
but all this has happened before I mean
you can call it reform rather than
Revolution here in the United States for
example uh our Founders and framers who
were such a brilliant crew
um basically created a republic of
gentlemen
then in the early 20th century that was
drastically changed and what was erected
was the system that we're not trying to
leave behind that 20th century Mass
system uh that that basically
Incorporated Incorporated literally tens
of millions of people that were just
entering history at that time and at the
bottom of these Mass structures like
mass production Mass parties mass
movements you know uh less consumerism
Mass entertainment
um so the system has been changed the
institutions have been changed they can
be changed again we think of them we
think we call it the federal government
and we call it you know
um the state governments and we think of
them as if they have been the same from
the from George Washington's day to our
own they're very different if Thomas
Jefferson one of my favorite persons in
history woke up and then he's also a
Virginian like I am and took a look at
what was going on with the government
today he would crawl back in his grave
and never come out again okay it's a
very different world a different
different set of institutional World
from the one he expected would be
created so
we can change the institutions we can
move them from the past to the Future
um it's happened before
um some will wither away and that's fine
um some will be drastically altered I
don't think any will be unchanged all of
them will be changed in some way or
another
yeah
that's yeah I keep so I keep reiterating
that's a good point because
the thing that I Like About You Martin
is that your answers are very measured
and it's very easy in these times to be
a polemicist to go one way or another
because as you said before it gets
clicks
yeah exactly we need the million views
Martin tell me Society is going to
crumble Rumble but what
what technology is going to play because
it's obviously going to play a major
part and now we're going to see the rise
of AI and I know you don't do
predictions but you can already see
things are being shaped by technology
I mean information structure
um
sets the stage and arranges the props
for the human drama part of the reason
that we cannot go back to the 20th
century is because we have a 20th
century stage set and
um and the props are arranged for the
21st century and the elites you know I
sometimes I probably shouldn't use this
uh comparison because most young people
don't even know what I'm talking about
you guys know what the Marx brothers
were yeah of course okay well don't say
of course you'd be surprised a number of
young people that I say that through it
and they go huh so
21st century stage is set for something
like a Marx Brothers comedy it's going
to slapstick a reverend crazy makes no
sense
um people falling down people standing
up
um
the elites desperately want to play
Hamlet you know
it's Shakespeare it's epic it's
important but the problem is this you
know even if you play Hamlet it's gonna
be Groucho Marx playing Hamlet and he's
gonna do Pratt Falls all right so it
just can't work it just can't work so
technology is going to play a
fundamental part in this it's already
played a fundamental part now it comes
the human aspect now comes the human
moment where we take the technology and
and make it our own in a way hopefully
if things go right in a way that
sustains democracy and sustains our
prosperity and um maybe tones down the
the incentive for conflict
and I mean what gives you reason to Hope
because a lot of the times when we talk
about this when we talk about these
issues people say you know they point
out the things that we should worry
about and of course that's a valid
argument but we don't also talk about
the positives as well
yeah okay let's go back to the 30th 30
Years War all right
um I always tell like to tell a story
that uh my friend
um Antonio Garcia Martinez a fellow
Cuban uh
tells which is if you want to a 30 Years
War which by the way was the most
devastating war in Europe including
World War II ever uh I think Germany it
took like three or four generations to
even go back to this former population
um if you go back to that war and
interview the man in the street and ask
him what do you think of the printing
press
that person would say it's the most
destructive horrible and and uh um evil
Innovation ever take it away and destroy
it because at that time people were
coming out of church with their their
little you know Hymnal and my Hymnal had
those three words that were different
from yours and now I had to kill you and
you had to kill me right so the printing
press was responsible for this
fragmentation which tends to happen with
new information structures
um and
it was
um basically it it was represented in
hideous horrible violence
we're not there okay you want to be
optimistic this is not the 30 Years War
come on look around you look around yes
we're yelling at each other but you know
what it just flipped down the the
um the monitor on your laptop and okay I
can tell you I'm looking if I were to do
that I would be looking at the window of
my neighborhood in Vienna Virginia where
people are peacefully walking their dogs
and waving at each other as they pass in
the streets and I don't know whether
they are pro-trump or or they are
provoke or they're any they're just my
neighbors okay and they and they're
walking their dogs or they're just
exercising or whatever so
this is not the 30 Years War let's not
exaggerate the conflict I think part of
what Tower of Babel effect is it's so
loud it's so uproarious uh and it's so
surrounding us if we're in line it's
just everywhere but this is not life
we're not shooting at each other we're
not killing each other mostly all right
so so I if you want to be optimistic we
can get past this moment it took 150
years for the human race to figure out
what to do with the printing press and
it probably won't take as long things
move faster now to to figure out the
digital information structure but it
will take a long time it will take a
long time and then we may get there
without massive Bloodshed so far there
hasn't been any well that is certainly a
good thing although of course I would
argue that uh some of the excesses of
the what people call the culture War it
does bleed out into real life I mean if
you look at the trans issue for example
there are real world impacts of that
particular world view on on young people
and and women in particular but of
course you're right we're not killing
each other and and the Curious Thing for
me speaking of killing each other is
what do you think the impact is of this
on the west uh versus its uh adversaries
let's put it gently because we spend a
lot of time in the west you know doing
this Division and argument and conflict
thing in a way that other cultures are
not are we making ourselves more
vulnerable or or will the West Prevail
in this situation what are your thoughts
yeah what is the West I mean that is
such an old-fashioned uh category right
that you would probably get banned in uh
Twitter you know before musk by even
using that term I
look I I
intuitively would agree with you except
I'm looking at the world this is what I
do right this is what I've been trained
to do
um I'm looking at the world and let's
not talk about the West let's talk about
liberal democracy okay
and okay what are where what are the
rivals of liberal democracy well again
back in the 20th century there was a
severe there were several there were
several major Rivals liberal democracy
at a certain point that was before my
time uh was considered to be
old-fashioned and useless right and the
fascists and the Nazis and the and the
Bolsheviks all had better ways
um well where are those systems now well
they basically have bit the Dust
what is the ideological rival what
system is the arrival of liberal
democracy today there is none right and
what countries are undemocratic and
hostile to us because we are democratic
well
look at Iran it's a mess people are
shouting from the rooftops I was
watching this video shouting from the
rooftops of Tehran you know
uh
Ayatollah you're a dictator go away
resign right I mean there there's
tremendous tremendous uh anti-government
anti-regime uh upsurge of anger look at
Russia Russia is a barrier that got
stuck in its old trap I mean it it it it
thought it was going to walk over uh
Ukraine and it's got this Army that is
so so incredibly incompetent that um uh
it it essentially
can't move forward incapable of
aggressive uh uh maneuvers
and it's got a demographic hole that the
entire country is falling in so that in
in another generation or so Russia being
a power won't even be a consideration
look at China we would have thought well
they're the ones they're the ones that
are really kind of
pushing us back well not that long ago
people were yelling in the streets of
China you know you are you are a
dictator resigned the Communist party is
no good because I had imposed this this
bizarre
um zero covet policy on the on the
public and you would see video see this
is the information environment you can
see videos of people yelling from their
balconies you can see videos of somebody
somebody whose wives had jumped from a
balcony because they have been stuck
alone for so long she's been depressed
and she killed herself
um so and what happened well the mighty
G reverses his zero policy I mean zero
covet positive I mean on a dime they
must either he was scared and backed
away or there are still people in that
very very opaque regime who can Force
action policies that he doesn't like uh
because they backed away on a dime so
they're also in some kind of trouble so
we are a mess look starting with the
United States you know the American
people are suffering what I call a
psychotic episode
we're a mess but everything in life what
you learn
is relative uh and I I look at
I kindly didn't speak of Europe but
um you know I look at everybody who is
not the United States and certainly
everybody who's not Democratic and
relatively speaking their bigger mess
than we are
well there's a relief people people are
even more messed up than we are uh
Martin it's been a pleasure speaking
with you we're going to ask you a couple
of questions from our supporters that
they've already submitted but before we
do we always finish with the same
question which is what is the one thing
that we're not talking about as a
society that you think we really should
be
yeah I would say
um it should be how do we
reform ourselves so that's a moral
question in other words uh morality is
very very
um uh it's hard to talk about and I I
tend not to talk about it because I I
feel like I know a lot about the few
fusible things but morality is about
being right and why the heck should you
listen to anything I've got to say you
don't know who I am I could be a bad
person so
um we each can only do that from the
inside and talked about it briefly
before that we need to kind of Step Back
From thinking that
people who are
online are somehow they have direct
influence on our lives you have
influenced your life what happens on the
computer screen doesn't have that much
influence on your life and number two
reform the institutions I I think our
politics are very policy driven but
instead of talking about policies we
need to talk about institutional reform
because whatever policy we settle on for
example on immigration you under the
current institutional framework are
going to spark a Revolt of at least 50
of the public and probably more right so
we need to reform those institutions
make them more like Amazon and less like
you know the Great Pyramid of Egypt
um and it concerns me honestly that we
keep fighting about the the marginalia
the the the policies
um instead of getting to the heart of
the matter which is how do we how do we
move from the 20th century institution
into the 21st Martin it's been an
absolute pleasure thank you so much if
people want to find you online
ironically enough if they want to buy
your books where is the best place to do
that
well Amazon of course you could buy the
book there I mean I think even in in
Britain these days it's it's at the
bookstore so it can be
um and online I I am mostly I mean I I
write way too much and you can find me
at discourse uh and um at City journal
for example there are two of my favorite
places to to write for
um so that's that's pretty much where
thank you so much for coming on stay
with us for the bonus questions but for
now thank you so much and thank you guys
for watching and listening we will see
you very soon with another brilliant
episode like this one Aurora show all of
them go out at 7pm UK time and for those
of you who like your trigonometry on the
go it's also available as a podcast take
care and see you soon guys
what advice would you give anyone who
wants to diminish their digital
footprint particularly with respect to
government and big business
[Music]
foreign